[Music]
Promote Islamic Tehzeeb in your life
Presenting Peace Mobile The
solution for humanity My Islamic
Smartphone
4.63 inch LED
screen Charming
body Excellent build
Beautiful
design Double SIM 32GB SD card and
4GB internal memory Double core
processor 5 megapixel auto focus camera
Live Peace TV English Urdu and Bengali
More than 80 hours of Dr. Zakir Naik's
video programs More than 50 must-have
Islamic
applications More than 100 Islamic
wallpapers More than 200 Islamic ringtones
Islamic AR Islam and other
books by Mazahir Zakir Naik Full peace Enjoy
life Connect with my technology
Strengthen spiritual bond with the Creator Put your life on Islamic lines
Feel the difference
Pas mo humanity ke liye saal mein majeed majeed haal To order
or buy
log on to www.com
[Music]